what's up guys dr. Mike here people
often ask me what's it really like to be
a doctor
hello sick people and their loved ones
come on you gotta be kidding me
alright alright let's talk about what
it's really like to be in the hospital
I've been at numerous hospitals I've
spent countless hours in hospitals so I
want to share with you my journey of
what it's like behind the scenes and
share some really cool stories with you
let's get started
I know what question you want answered
first is there so much loving going on
in the hospital that we just can't
control ourselves
no I have seen some residents hit it off
I've seen some doctors and nurses hit it
off before and start dating outside of
the hospital so it does occur but it
rarely probably never occurs to the
extent that people are getting it on in
janitorial closets I will say this I do
work with some nurses who are in their
60s and they've told me that 20-30 years
ago it was more like that they did go
and visit some doctors in the back rooms
and in the boiler rooms and maybe 20 30
years ago before my time it was more
romantic and similar to Grey's Anatomy
sorry for those of you who wanted this
but there's just not that much romance
that goes on in hospitals excuse me next
topic money
everyone thinks that doctors are rich
the first thing I have to say right off
the bat is med school is very expensive
think Ferrari expensive quarter million
dollars expensive then the first three
to five years of being a doctor out of
medical school you're being paid a
residents salary which is very low when
I was training it ranged anywhere from
40 to $50,000 a year not a terrible
salary I agree with you but you're
working sometimes 80 to 100 hours a week
if you calculate what that comes out to
hourly you're making around nine to ten
dollars an hour that's less than minimum
wage in some places and then once you
start a practice you have to pay your
malpractice insurance which is sky-high
for some specialties
be a practicing ob/gyn in New York City
you're paying sometimes a hundred two
hundred thousand dollars a year alone
for coverage
that's just coverage then if you want to
open up your own practice you have to
pay for the space you want to hire a
nurse and a PA and a scribe and this and
that you have to pay for that as well
but guess what you still have a quarter
million dollars in loans that you
haven't been able to pay back so the
whole notion that doctors are rich right
off the bat and it's an easy career that
you can just go on and make a lot of
money false myth busted my student loan
debt upon graduating medical school
because I had some scholarships was
around 220,000 or so during my residency
you would make payments and they
wouldn't be large payments because they
would be based on your income it's
called income based repayment but I
noticed that after two years of making
these payments my amount that I owed
actually went up because of the
percentage just what I thought I was out
the next most common question probably
deals with losing a patient and being a
resident when you're on called you're in
the hospital at night and you're
basically responsible for any
emergencies that go down so if there's a
code blue which means that someone's
heart has stopped you're the one that
has to run there to resuscitate them to
bring them back to life so to answer the
question absolutely I've lost patients
on my watch not every resident or doctor
handles death the same way and we get a
lot of coaching and education about what
the right way to handle death is and I
don't think there's ever a right way but
the one good point that I've seen at
these coaching sessions is that it's
important to not forcefully hide your
emotions and that's a natural instinct
that some people do they say I'm a
doctor I shouldn't cry showing emotion
is not a bad thing it's that when you
let emotion take over you and it stops
you from making quality decisions that's
where it sort of crosses in the
territory where it impedes your work
it's very difficult to find the words to
share with the family members to help
console them but you're the person
you're the one that has to be there I
remember a specific story one night I
was on call
and there was a code blue in the ICU
there was a man he was in his 90s and
his heart stopped we tried to
resuscitate him it was unsuccessful and
he end up passing and his wife of 65
plus years was sitting immediately
outside of the room and I had to be the
one to break the news to her so I got on
on my knee I sort of held her hand and I
explained her everything what happened
and she was in shock
rightfully so she just lost a partner
she's been living with for over half a
century so I told her what happened I
explained that she was very
understanding and kind and I realized
there wasn't anything more I needed to
say but I couldn't leave I still needed
to be there so I sat with her for
probably 20 minutes on my knee just
holding her hand and after 20 minutes of
sitting there she looked at me and just
said thank you and that's what she
needed luckily for me that I didn't have
a page during that moment that I would
have to leave you want to give everyone
the proper amount of time and have the
conversation to its full capacity right
to make sure the person is okay with
what happened they understand everything
that's going on but remember you're
responsible for the entire hospital so
your pagers constantly going off there's
other medical emergencies happening
simultaneously so not only do you have
to be very kind and understanding of
what's going on you also have to be
realistic and explain to them that
you're gonna be back you have to deal
with another emergency because you are
the doctor that's responsible for the
entire hospital if you ever find
yourself in a hospital and you see that
the doctor is very stressed out or feels
like they're not just giving you the
proper amount of time ask if something
urgent is going on that they need to
attend to first and so that they can
come back maybe and explain to you
what's going on in a little bit because
it's very rare that a doctor is being
rude just to be rude or a nurse is being
rude just to be rude most of the time
it's because we're very busy especially
nowadays with insurance companies
clamping down on profits the hospitals
are often slightly understaffed and we
want to give you the proper amount of
time and often times is there's just so
many things going on that we oftentimes
can't as important as it is to talk
about moments of death maja
but all there's also some really
uplifting moments when it comes to life
being a family medicine physician I
delivered just over 30 babies in
Overland achill Center one of the moms
that I had in the OB clinic she had a
very difficult pregnancy she had a
complication regarding her gallbladder
where she Anna have her gallbladder
removed while she was pregnant she had a
very protracted delivery was very long i
sat there probably with her you know for
20 hours and we were doing checks every
now and then to make sure that her
cervix was still progressing and that we
didn't need to give her any medications
and it was progressing versus
progressing very slowly and then at
midnight it's like the baby knew it's
like it's midnight dr. mike is exhausted
it's time for me to poke my head out so
we started the delivery baby came out
perfect crying right away I didn't have
to spank the baby's bottom just kidding
you don't have to do that instantly take
the baby and put the baby on the moms
chest so they can have some interaction
looking at the mom's face immediately
after the delivery is such an amazing
moment because it's a complex emotion
that she's showing she's anxious once
reassurance that the baby's okay she's
happy she's excited there's just so much
emotion that comes out and that one
first smile when the baby's first born
there's really nothing else like it
finally let's talk about the
inaccuracies that come with some of
these TV shows as a doctor it's painful
to watch them at times because there's a
lot of medical errors that are made they
shock asystole with the paddles and not
everybody understands that but as a
doctor it's so frustrating to see them
give bad medical care in the TV dramas
doctors do everything they meet the
patient in the ER they take them for the
scans they perform the scans they read
the scans there's a lot of nursing care
involved there and it's a shame that
these medical dramas leave the nurses
out the nurse will not only take your
vitals they'll give you their
medications pretty much the only
interaction you have with a doctor is
describing what's going on hearing what
the doctor's point of view is and that's
pretty much hid the rest of the time
you're being surrounded by tech staff
EMA's nursing staff and
the people who are really the backbone
of medicine that I applaud and I feel
like don't get recognized enough in TV
dramas I hope you enjoyed hearing about
my experiences in the hospital system
it's definitely an interesting place as
you can tell I'm very passionate about
it so if you want to learn more and you
have some questions or comments leave
them down below as you know that I'm
very active in the comments section I
have a fun proposition for you if you
get this video to 10,000 likes which is
very doable you've done that for a lot
of my videos already I will watch a
Grey's Anatomy episode or whatever show
you guys want me to watch leave it down
below in the comments not only will i
watch that episode i will film myself
watching the episode and talk about
what's going on it'll be a dedicated
video on just that subject I know a lot
of you have asked me to watch Grey's
Anatomy before and I've never seen an
episode so I think it's gonna be a fun
challenge get this video to 10,000 likes
as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you